this by president zolensky was
extraordinary he isn't in a secure
bunker safely away from the action he is
right on the front line next to some of
the fiercest fighting of this conflict
in the town of lucif chance
just think what message these pictures
send to the soldiers and the ukrainian
people
just think what message it sends to the
kremlin can you imagine vladimir putin
taking this kind of risk
each family has its own story most were
without men someone's husband went to
war someone's is in captivity someone's
unfortunately died a tragedy no home no
loved one but we must live for the
children true heroes they are among us
this is what it looks like above ground
the shelling is relentless as both sides
dig in and fight for small gains
but the battle could be pivotal and so
that's why zelinski put himself right in
the middle of it to g up his troops and
why russia is throwing everything at it
they put too much
is there they put too much effort and we
still have a difference in numbers of
and in capabilities that is why we so
like a weight in
uh all the military systems which we
should gain with the better artillery
better air defense and
which provide us a better capability to
hold on and to then to make a
counteroffensive
those weapons are now on their way the
americans and british are providing them
and they are expected to be here soon
the russians aren't happy
yesterday
if all of this on the part of the united
states and its satellites is a reaction
to what is happening then i will
emphasize again the longer the range
system supplied to the kiev regime will
have the farther we will push the nazis
from the line from where they could
threaten the russians in ukraine and the
russian federation
both sides are fighting this war at huge
cost the death toll is enormous
the faces of the dead ukrainian soldiers
line a long wall in the centre of kiev
now
civilian deaths too cemeteries are now
filling with freshly dug graves it is no
exaggeration to say that some burial
grounds are simply running out of room
the sacrifice being made in defense of
this country
could at times leave you speechless
astabanka sky news in eastern ukraine